[Musik]
so viel Liebe war lange nicht für die
Politik der neue Star im Kabinett heißt
Boris Pistorius endlich hat die Truppe
den Verteidigungsminister den sie
verdient weiter so ich habe ein gutes
Gefühl bei ihm er hat schon einen so
kurzer Zeit so viel geregelt dieses Amt
ist wie maßgeschneidert für Herrn
Pistorius seit Ewigkeiten wieder ein
vernünftiger Verteidigungsminister ja
das sind so die Social Media Kommentare
die ich gefunden habe und sogar die Bild
ist verknallt darum lieben alle Boris
schreibt sie ich freue mich über gute
Beliebtheitswerte weiß aber auch dass
das im Laufe der Zeit abnehmen wird so
ist das politische Geschäft abgeben
Soldaten zuhören Kabinettskollegen
umarmen das alles macht er eigentlich in
seinen ersten 100 Tagen ziemlich gut und
selbst die
Opposition also die politische
Konkurrenz ist erstmal begeistert von
dem neuen nach einem verlorenen Jahr mit
Christine Lambrecht ist ein zupackender
Boris Pistorius das Richtige für die
Bundeswehr entscheidend ist aber was er
wirklich praktisch durchsetzen kann
dabei ist der Druck auf den neuen
Verteidigungsminister riesig das ist die
letzte Patrone wenn dieser
Verteidigungsminister keinen Erfolg hat
dann scheitert die ganze Bundesregierung
naja aber diese letzte Patrone hat
zumindest erstmal keine Fehlzündung
hingelegt und selbst nüchterne
Diplomaten outen sich als Fanboys von
Pistorius vielen Dank dass Sie da sind
sie machen darf als pensionierter war
sie machen Deutschlands beliebtester
Politiker heißt also gerade Boris
Pistorius und das wollen wir doch jetzt
alle mal wissen wie kommt das und kann
er wirklich der Retter der Bundeswehr
sein Achtung Spoiler eins ist sicher wer
in der Politik hoch fliegt der muss mit
einer besonders harten Landung rechnen
[Applaus]
ich bin Christiane hübscher
Korrespondentin im Hauptstadtstudio des
ZDF und kümmere mich hier auch um
Verteidigungspolitik gerade war ich mit
Boris Pistorius auf Dienstreise in
Afrika in Mali und Niger um genau zu
sein und ich bin das verschwitzte etwas
was sie da unten rechts im Bild seht ja
und ich würde gerne gleich mal ein paar
meiner Beobachtungen von dieser Reise
mit euch teilen was ist das
Erfolgsgeheimnis dieses Ministers den
außerhalb von Niedersachsen doch vor 100
Tagen noch kaum jemand kannte da wäre
erstens der Pistorius Sound
bei ihm gibt's keine s keine Politiker
Schachtelsätze keine nicht antworten er
formuliert militärisch knapp aber ebenso
das ist doch jeder versteht in Mali zum
Beispiel wird Pistorius gefragt warum
der Abzug der Bundeswehr noch ein ganzes
Jahr dauern muss und da sagt er das ist
kein Umzug einer fünfköpfigen Familie
mit einem Umzugswagen das ist eine
militärische logistische Operation die
man nicht mal eben so im Vorbeigehen
macht und deswegen braucht sie auch die
Zeit der Minister nimmt auf solche
Reisen auch Fachpolitiker mit also
Verteidigungspolitiker der anderen
Parteien und zwei von ihnen habe ich in
Afrika mal gefragt wie sie die
Kommunikation von Pistorius bis jetzt zu
finden als Typus kommt er natürlich an
weil er einfach geradeaus ist und in der
Sprache auch sehr klar er trifft den
richtigen Ton er spricht so dass
Menschen ihn auch wirklich verstehen man
hat auch immer den Eindruck das was er
sagt dass meint er auch und das kommt
halt einfach bei den Soldaten und
Soldaten sehr gut an und auch mit
internationalen Gesprächspartnern
funktioniert der neue Minister gut denn
er spricht mehrere Sprachen russisch zum
Beispiel aber eben auch gut genug
Französisch und Englisch
[Musik]
zum Beispiel nicht die Sprache ist also
das eine aber da ist noch was
der nahbare
Boris Pistorius lässt Nähe zu in erster
Linie natürlich mit Soldatinnen und
Soldaten klar das ist ein Job
einmal die Woche raus
aber auch mit Journalisten ihr seht hier
Bilder aus dem Flieger nach Afrika das
nennt sich Hintergrundgespräch was ihr
da seht der Minister kommt also während
des Fluges nach hinten zur Mitreisenden
Presse und erzählt mal bisschen mehr das
darf alles nicht geschrieben oder
gesendet werden was man da hört das ist
nur für unseren Hintergrund eben gedacht
das machen grundsätzlich eigentlich alle
Politiker aber manche lassen selbst im
Hintergrund nicht wirklich was raus gibt
der meist schon etwas mehr Preis der
erklärt sich wirklich und nach einem
Hintergrund mit ihm versteht man
tatsächlich wo er steht was ihm so durch
den Kopf geht gerade und vielleicht
erklärt das ja auch ein bisschen die
gute Presse die der Minister gerade
genießen und beide ist der Ton und die
narbarkeit gehören natürlich zur benote
noch wichtiger ist
die Riesenaufgabe
ja und hier endet dann auch die Lob
pudelei denn kommen wir mal zur Sache
Pistorius hat mir der Bundeswehr krasse
Aufgaben vor sich kurz zur Erinnerung
für uns alle verteilungsminister fängt
nicht bei Null an sondern bei -10 oder
bei -100 das heißt also er muss mit den
Fehlern der Vergangenheit erstmal leben
und auf der anderen Seite der
Wiederaufbau des deutschen
verteidigungssektors wird 10 15 Jahre
dauern der Verteidigungsminister muss
liefern nicht nur Panzer in die Ukraine
sondern auch sonst es fehlt das ist ja
bekannt der Bundeswehr an allem von der
Unterhose bis zur Panzerhaubitze hat er
genug Ahnung von der Materie also er ist
arbeitet sich sehr schnell ein und ich
glaube was ihm wirklich hilft erstens
ist ja hat er Verwaltungserfahrung als
Oberbürgermeister und er war zehn Jahre
Innenminister und war dafür die innere
Sicherheit zuständig war auch
international diesbezüglich unterwegs
bist du jetzt selbst sagt mir im
Interview der größte Schock für ihn war
dieser unglaublich aufgeblähte
Verwaltungsapparat den er bei
Amtsantritt im Ministerium vorgefunden
hat wie viele unter ist in diesem Haus
braucht bevor etwas wirklich
entscheidungsreif ist und kein Wunder
schaut mal das hier das ist das
Organigramm also die Verwaltungsstruktur
des Verteidigungsministeriums das sind
also wahnsinnig viele ich denke hunderte
von Kästchen ja in den alle Funktionen
die Sie in diesem Hause gibt und Posten
aufgeführt sind ja und diese
Verwaltungsstruktur ist in den letzten
15 bis 20 Jahren einfach immer
ausladender geworden ich mache seit über
30 Jahren Verwaltung und politische
Führung auf verschiedenen Ebenen oder
fast 30 Jahren und habe viele
Organigramme gesehen und selber auch an
ihn gearbeitet als ich dies da war mir
relativ schnell klar dass so man ein so
riesen Haus nicht führen kann 3000
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in
Berlin und Bonn seine Vorgängerin hätten
sich da nicht dran getraut zu erzählt es
Pistorius er aber will jetzt
durchgreifen will den Apparat
verschlanken und Strafen wir beginnen
also oben in der Spitze es wird auch
kein stellenaufwuchs geben die Büros der
beteiligt werden reduziert werden im
Kern geht's also darum die Spitze zu ver
Produkten und effizienter zu machen und
dann in den weiteren Schritten die
weiteren Ebenen eben auch zu
modernisieren und schneller zu machen ja
und das tut wirklich Not sagt die grüne
Agnieszka Brucker Entscheidung bleiben
zu lange liegen es ist unklar wo die
Reise hingehen soll und deshalb gab es
eine Reihe von strukturprozessen
Ankündigung Papiere Unternehmensberatung
Beraterinnen und Berater die wirklich
sehr viel Papier produziert haben aber
am Ende des Tages sind eigentlich
Entscheidungen nicht getroffen worden
Pistorius entscheidet der hat
tatsächlich auch schon die ersten Posten
ausgetauscht der erste der gehen musste
war gleich der Rang höchste general
Generalinspektor Zorn hier seht ihr
Bilder seines Zapfenstreichs der neue
ist kassenbreuer hier im Bild rechts
daneben ein Minister der derart
einschneidende Maßnahmen ergreift muss
begründen was diejenigen die abgelöst
werden falsch gemacht haben sollen dazu
habe ich nichts gehört was hat er
bisherige Generalinspektor falsch
gemacht das wusste ich gerne und als
nächstes hat Pistorius die Chefin des
beschaffungsamtes Gabriele Korb in den
Ruhestand geschickt das war natürlich
nicht freiwillig und deshalb geht die
auch mit lautem Türen knallen hier das
ist die Abschiedsbrief an die
Belegschaft des
bundeswehrbeschaffungsamts in Koblenz
darin schreibt sie das Amt sein nahezu
immer der Prügelknabe wenn Beschaffung
angeblich nicht läuft und lassen Sie
sich von Zweifler nicht demotivieren
schreibt sie noch das ist ganz klar
Kritik am neuen Minister also ich nehme
jede Kritik und jede kritische Äußerung
sehr ernst aber mein gesamteindruckend
die Kritik erhält sich wirklich in
Grenzen dass der überwiegende Teil des
Hauses das war ein fester Eindruck aus
den vielen Gesprächen ist gerade zu
ungeduldig dass es weitergeht dass ich
was verändert dass die guten Leute die
in dem Haus arbeiten auf allen Ebenen
auch wirklich das was sie leisten können
und in der Vergangenheit nicht leisten
konnten wegen der Strukturen und der
Abläufe jetzt endlich quasi die PS auf
die Straße bringen wie man so sagt und
dann wird historius noch den zentralen
Planungs- und Führungsstab wieder
einführen mit einem General an der
Spitze Christian freuding vielleicht
kennt ihr den sogar der ist in der
ukraine-krise als Kriegserklärung sowas
wie ein YouTube-Star geworden das was da
erreicht wurde darauf könnte ukrainische
Streitkräfte auch mit Recht stolz sein
Freundin soll künftig die Aufträge der
Leitung im Apparat durchsetzen und
Kritik ungefiltert von unten nach oben
weiterleiten was noch ein generaler
Ministerium da machen die ersten auf
fürchten eine Entmachtung der
stadtsekretäre was wir nicht brauchen
ist eine zusätzliche militärische
Führung des Ministeriums das ist die
vornehmer Aufgabe der zivilen
Staatssekretäre na klar macht er sich
jetzt auch Feinde sagt Marie Agnes
strafzimmermann das ist natürlich nie
beliebt und es ist auch nicht dass ein
die einzige Lösung personalauszutauschen
ich glaube aber es ist wichtig wir haben
leben in einer zeitenwände die muss auch
bei der Bundeswehr vor allen Dingen bei
den Offizieren eben
Verteidigungsministerium ankommen zu
glauben der Minister kommt und geht wir
bleiben ich glaube das sollte sich jeder
jetzt mal abschminken und insofern tut
er gut daran Positionen zu verändern na
dann
was könnte schief gehen
tja was könnte schief gehen die Minister
persönlich ist also der Kaltstart
gelungen aber der Bundeswehr geht es
stand heute unter ihm kein bisschen
besser als vorher die Truppe steht über
ein Jahr nach der Ankündigung der Zeiten
Wände schlechter da als je zuvor weil
sie Material an die Ukraine abgibt dass
dann aber gar nicht nachbestellt wird
das her könne seine Aufgabe nicht
glaubwürdig wahrnehmen meldet neulich
erst wieder heeresinspektor Alfons Mais
Pistorius braucht also Geld und zwar
viel mehr als die 100 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen 10 Milliarden zusätzlich
hat er bei Finanzminister Lindner für
nächstes Jahr beantragt so viel wird er
nicht kriegen das weiß ja auch schon und
was dann wenn er nicht erfolgreich wird
bist Du jetzt kokettiert an dieser
Stelle immer so ein bisschen im
Gegensatz zu seinen Vorgängerinnen habe
er keine Angst er keine echte Reform
durchsetzen und er müsse auch gar nichts
mehr werden ich bin jetzt 63 Jahre alt
und habe einige berufliche Stationen
hinter mir ich liebe diese Aufgabe die
ich jetzt gerade mache aber ich muss sie
nicht machen um sie als sprungbrette zu
haben für irgendetwas weiteres und von
daher bin ich relativ gelassen in der
Situation und das hilft und was meint
ihr wie gefällt euch dieser radikale
Boris Pistorius der gerade ziemlich viel
anpackt habt ihr Vertrauen in seinen
Führungsstil kann er wirklich die
Bundeswehr retten oder ist das einer der
als Tiger startet und als Bettvorleger
landen wird schreibt uns eure Meinung in
die Kommentare und schaut gerne all
unsere anderen Videos